it's fascinating because you've done
this very intense and and uh beloved
work and you explore these intense
themes but because of your Fame and
notoriety you're also being
asked uh to do these other side projects
which um are very popular in popular
culture you've been uh a guest on The
Simpsons yes more than once Mandalorian
Mandalorian you're in the Mandalorian
yes uh Jack Reacher Parks and Recreation
yeah and I'm curious where
you've how you uh reconcile because it's
such a Chasm between uh being in Peru um
you're life-threaten by a Madman trying
to make this magnum opus and then you're
on the set of The Simpsons or you're
with uh baby Yoda on the Mandalorian
what is is it
uh it must be quite fascinating to
imagine the trips you've taken in your
life sure yes and it's I do not want to
miss any of that because I found the
Simpsons very
fascinating intelligent and and a lot of
Anarchy in it MH and when I was invited
to speak a role I immediately said do
they speak I cannot believe that I
thought there were only like comic
strips printed in newspapers i' had
never seen it and I think Matt groaning
who started it he said to me don't don't
you know since 24 years we are on on TV
station one of the most popular TV shows
of all time around the world I did not
know that that it existed so I I I I
asked I asked for DVD to show me a
little bit so that I could see how or
hear how cartoonish the voices would be
yeah they actually sent a few of them to
me and and they said you don't need to
be cartoonish just speak with your
accent it's wild enough wild enough for
us so and I I acknowledged yes and I
really really enjoyed it did I'm good at
I'm good at that and and in Jack Reacher
I they are bad guys they open fire they
have huge assault rifles they swear they
shout they yell at you they have fist
fights I'm the epicenter of uh of of
evil I have very few fingers left I ate
them in a gulak to avoid being sent to a
to a A Lead Mine and lose my life there
and I'm blind in I one one Blind Eye and
I only have my voice to spread Terror
and a calm voice and one of the villains
uh the sub villain who made a mistake I
tell him you can get away with it if
you're really determined not to do that
again you have to eat your fingers as I
do it as I did it yeah and he tries and
tries and I very calmly encourage him I
say that was that was already good you I
know you can do it just try harder and
and it's so frightening that uh when um
the film was out uh friends of my wife
in
Paris they all turned they said Lena are
you married to that
man you know you know we are only one
night flight away from you we can give
you
shelter so I I knew I was good and
that's that's my best my best reward did
you um the the the the Mandalorian
there's so much secrecy around that
shoot there's so much so no one can know
what's going to happen and how did you
uh what was that experience like for you
well secrecy went so far that uh I had
to sign a contract for a film
Huckleberry
Finn not Mandalorian they misnamed and
you had your costumes you couldn't leave
the studio unless you put a big tunic
all over you and you were not allowed to
speak about what was going on inside so
I understand that uh because it's such a
worldwide phenomenon and the fans were
lurking outside the hedges with their
with their little cameras and trying to
uh snap a few photos so um but but the
experience was was very very interesting
because John FAO who is a a mastermind
behind all this he invited me I was
always invited I never competed for any
part I never was in any audition and he
apparently
loves my films and loves my writings and
he wanted uh to make me as a person
visible for a larger audience in the
world that's a guy who did all these
things and you see we we are speaking
about my films and my acting but um
equally important I think is writing
from the very very beginning I've been a
writer and I started out writing when
when I was 15 16 and I published my
first
books uh decades ago in the early ' 70s
and they are still constantly being
reprinted reprinted and uh I keep saying
and it's basically to deaf ears and it
will fall on deaf ear ear here as well
but time is on my side I keep saying
um the written things my books my Pros
my poetry with all probability will have
a longer life than my films I will be
remembered for my writings not so much
for my films I I can I I wouldn't say
that that would fall on De ears here
because I
think yes the films I think and and no
one can say no one can really say but
the medium of the med the medium of film
uh can change so much that things can go
in and out of popularity but you write
beautifully uh you you are you are
terrific uh and disciplined writer and
your writing is very lyrical and I think
that that can travel through all kinds
of changes in how people experience
entertainment probably more safely and
durably than maybe film can so I think
that's possible books are more durable
than movies that's a strange thing but
it's it's it's a fact you can you can
see
it